bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france quel regard portez vous sur la
situation en tunisie vous considérer
qu'il s'agit là d'un coup d'état
oui c'est un coup d'état institutionnel
comme ça a été appelé dans l'est dans
les médias mais en réalité c'est tout à
fait cohérent avec le projet politique
de rachat est le projet politique de rsa
et qui s'articule autour d'un localisme
d'une volonté de créer des parlements
locaux qui décrédibilise le parlement
national et depuis sa campagne
électorale il n'a cessé de répéter que
le qu'il avait un souci majeur avec le
parlement et la petite question actuelle
en réalité ce qui s'est passé c'est une
concrétisation du projet politique de
réserve il s'est vanté elle a essayé
d'avoir gagné la présidentielle sont
partis aujourd'hui quelles formations
politiques le soutiennent les formations
politiques qui le soutiennent sont à
l'actif à qui est minoritaire au
parlement qu'il ya un petit bloc
il ya d'autres formations politiques qui
le soutiennent par nécessité dix ans
parce que cette volonté populaire de son
passage existe
attention à ne pas ne pas se tromper
même s'il s'agit d'un d'une sortie de la
constitution la majorité du peuple le
soutient
le vrai souci c'est que tu ailles side
oppose la majorité du peuple et la
majorité des électeurs qui ont voté aux
législatives qui sont tout à fait
légitimes aussi d'avoir leur
représentation politique
ses récentes décisions peuvent malgré
tout résoudre l'impasse politique dans
laquelle était plongé la tunisie est
bien un coup d'état est un coup d'état
c'est à dire que le 7 novembre 1983
quand ben ali arrivé au pouvoir il ya
cette même effervescence populaire il ya
cette notion de même joie et on se dit
qu'on va sortir de 2,2 de la dictature
et des problèmes politiques qu'elle
avait engendré à l'époque
moi je me dis que même si l'ennemi de
rice aride peut aussi être l'ennemi
d'une majorité de la population
tunisienne
beaucoup de tunisiens rejette nardin et
le parti islamiste
mais ça ne veut pas dire que son projet
politique est positif son projet
politique reste quand même quelque chose
qui est assez floue qui part d'un
principe de comités populaires locaux
est qui et qui persistent dans cette
idée là et même ses comités populaires
il
il veut à titre consultatif ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas des organes qui vont
prendre des décisions donc c'est ce
localisme plutôt consultatif qui est
censé remplacer le parlement qui est
inquiétant alors et nadal à la formation
islamiste s'est exprimé il ya quelques
instants elle qui dénonçait donc hier un
coup d'état elle se dit aujourd'hui
prête à la tenue d'élections
législatives et présidentielle
anticipées simultanée est ce que vous
pensez que c'est quelque chose que
pourraient mettre en place sarrail et
sayed je pense qu'il ne le fera pas je
pense que la dissolution du parlement
pour lui ne est un outil pour modifier
la constitution
même s'il n'a pas le droit de le faire
qu'il n'y a pas de cocon sionnel on a vu
que le ce n'est pas la légalité qui
l'empêché de concrétiser son projet
politique mais je pense que c'est la
solution la tenue d'élections anticipées
législatives et présidentielle parce que
là cette prise de position dans pride
pour moi ne peut le positionner que
comme président temporaire on ne peut
pas garder comme président de la
république
quelqu'un qui ne respecte pas la
constitution sauf s'il se représente et
qu'il regagne évidemment mais la tenue
d'élections anticipées législatives et
présidentielles pour moi est la seule
issue possible
un dernier mot rail sayed concentre
aujourd'hui tous les pouvoirs est ce que
cela représente un risque pour les
acquis démocratiques de la tunisie bien
sûr on l'a vu déjà à lire quand le
journal jazira a été a été confisqué par
les forces de l'ordre les journalistes
ont dû sortir le directeur du journal de
l'antenne de tunis a dit que c'est qu'il
n'avait jamais vécu ça en disant deux en
dix ans ici en tunisie
on a vu que les fonctionnaires n'ont pas
pu accéder à leur travail ce qui a
poussé à une décision de deux d'arrêt de
la fonction publique pendant deux jours
donc oui à d il ya des indices sur une
concentration des pouvoirs qui peut
s'avérer autoritaire au minimum et c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est naturel
quand on concentre tous les pouvoirs on
ne peut pas concentré tous les pouvoirs
et être démocrate
étant donné qu'il n'y a pas de
contre-pouvoirs n'y a pas de
possibilités pour pour l'opposition de
s'exprimer
merci beaucoup pour votre éclairage à
amina smoothie